okay imagine you're an esports athlete
in a relatively small scene
opportunities for you to shine are few
and far between so when you place well
at your scenes biggest events of the
year it's kind of a big deal
there is one serious problem though
because the organizer was in way over
their head because there was a loophole
in the contract you signed you don't get
your prize money paid out now it's nine
months after the event and you're
wondering if you'll ever see a dime and
how much money are we talking about here
over two hundred thousand dollars total
[Music]
okay guys before we go any further
really quickly I have to let you know
that we are streaming on Twitch pretty
regularly these days so head on over to
twitch.tv slash the score eSports give
us a follow and turn notifications on I
promise you won't regret it
okay so the story I'm gonna bring you
today takes place in the gods of boom
scene now what the hell is gods a boom
well really quickly it's a mobile fps
that kind of looks like Valarie gameplay
with four night graphics can you see
yourself on the stage in this degree of
Fame never comes free giving them
okay I promise to never play that clip
again anyways it's published by a
company called game insight who do a
bunch of mobile titles in the tycoon sim
and strategy genres a lot of the games
they publish seem to include slot
machine elements and the art style for
these is very reminiscent of the kind of
stuff you always see in actual physical
slot machines anybody who's been to a
casino out there knows exactly what I
mean God's a boom by the way it was
previously known as guns a boom until
they changed their name last year and it
was last year in November that they held
their biggest LAN events of the season
and that is the gods of boon Pro Series
Europe and the gods of boom season two
finals now I know we're dealing with a
mobile game here but we're actually not
talking about peanuts both events which
took place on consecutive days combined
for a prize pool of over $200,000 none
of which has apparently been paid out to
the winners of either event now that was
nine months ago and players
participating in these two events were
led to believe that they would be paid
out no later than three months after the
event ended now I spoke to a player
named Devine King his team came in
second in both the Pro Series Europe in
the season two finals the tool and
events that were talking about here and
he says players signed a contract that
seemed to say that they would be paid
out their prize money within 90 days of
the event ending so the event comes and
goes and game insights sends him and all
the other players who won a list of
necessary documents that they need to
pay them their prize money bank account
numbers proof of address that kind of
thing but on the very last day they were
supposed to be paid out divine King says
that game insight bombarded the players
with a completely new list of updated
documents that they would need to
provide in order to be paid the prize
money then they sent us more information
hey sorry we need more information from
you that was the day that she was
supposed to pay so they asked for more
information they wanted
first they wanted our a passport to be
on certified by notary ours banks they
need to be certified by notary and then
they asked for our tax certificate and
then they also asked for our criminal
record certificate
what criminal certificate it would take
sign you know we spoke to them and tell
them about the situation with the
criminal certificate that would that
would take a long time
so the toes they will be okay they just
needed us all the documents to be
certified see the players participating
in those two gods of boom events thought
that the contracts they signed
stipulated a 90-day payout in reality
the language of the payout clause in
that contract is extremely fuzzy and
unclear it states quote prizes will be
fulfilled within 90 days after the
conclusion of the event and receipt of
all necessary documentation end quote so
when you first read that sentence you
think oh okay I'm gonna get paid out
within 90 days of the event ending but I
also have to give them the necessary
documents but what if they ask for the
necessary documents after the 90 days
say in 100 days
what if they ask for the necessary
documents after a thousand days a
million you get the picture my point is
according to at least one interpretation
of this very fuzzy and vague language
game insight could go on asking for new
documentation every 90 days until
presumably the end of time now whether
that would actually stand up in a court
of law I can't say because I'm not a
lawyer but I have my doubts personally
now it's after game insight missed their
first 90 day pay period that divine King
says that communication between the
publisher and the players they owe
$200,000 to began to really break down
the communication was really bad we send
an e mails how the process was going
they never respond we're in a situation
that has been almost like seven months
without getting the price money like we
feel very frustrating it's like we don't
know what to do
we made a public statement with the help
with a lawyer they responded back saying
how is because of the Kobe night
saying that the process has delay and I
understand but now in June things got
better the economy opened banks open up
we don't really know what's going on or
if they're really gonna pay or we don't
know and this process kind of repeats
itself with game insight asking for more
documentation several times in February
and then again in March Devine says that
he and all the other players who are
owed money did everything they could to
stay in contact with the publisher and
push them for updates on when they were
getting the money that they were owed
emails discord messages you name it and
after a while all they started getting
back was either silence or very generic
messages that basically said were
working on it and that's why in May
Devine and a number of other players
decided to go public and after that the
publisher did respond in a public
discord message game insight talked
about the difficulties they faced
because of Kovac 19 and because of the
diverse nature of their player base
which meant that different paperwork had
to be done different ways in different
countries and at all complicated matters
and if you're thinking that this kind of
paperwork is something the publisher
should have had a better handle on
before they decided to host their own
$200,000.00 tournaments well I would
tend to agree with you now there is of
course another side to this story I did
reach out to game insight for their take
on this situation their CEO a guy named
Anatoly rabbitov responded to me and
told me that previously gods of boom
tournaments were organized by ESL the
two events in November that we're
talking about in this video were the
first ones that game insight themselves
put on and organized alone and the CEO
tells me that it turns out organizing
the logistics for major land tournaments
and their subsequent payouts were a lot
more difficult than game in sight
initially thought specifically the CEO
told me quote we learned the hard way
that having prize money in an escrow
account paying it out to team members in
different countries while adhering to
local regulations and complying with
accounting intricacies is a far more
challenging and time-consuming job than
we ever expected we didn't anticipate
the difficulties in doing that man you
and have slipped in our timelines and
quote now roppa tov also made it clear
to me in our email correspondence that
kovat 19 and the resulting lock downs
were a contributing factor to their
difficulties in paying out their players
but that it should be putting near the
bottom of the list of factors which
frankly doesn't really jive with their
public messaging or their private
dialogues with players divine King told
me that Kovac 19 was consistently used
as the major excuse for why payment
hadn't been delivered yet and it's
because of the banks because of the
lockdown that's what they told us
because of the lockdown
everything was shut down in lieu tanja
that's the place everything was shut
down and all the processed stuff so we
understood that it's a lie but when can
you guys pay us like when when it's the
timeline and the Cheetos they don't know
we keep asking them like the timeline
and they always abort that question now
I did bring up this inconsistency to
rabbitov and what he told me it was
quote we're talking about the adverse
combination of factors that led to the
current events we didn't anticipate the
initial difficulties and with the
consequences of the kovat lockdown the
situation became even more challenging
I'm sure we will deliver the commitments
we made in the coming weeks all of the
players will receive further
instructions shortly now that statement
which references a few weeks in the
future was sent to me more than a week
and a half ago and I have confirmed with
a lawyer who's working with a group of
players that since then nothing has
changed and no such instructions have
been issued now I will say that I do
appreciate the forthrightness of the CEO
of game insight here usually when I deal
with these kind of situations and I
reach out to the publishers or the
tournament organizers or whoever it is
that owes the money they either
disappear off the face of the earth and
completely ghost me they give me no
comment or they give me one very small
PR statement that basically says nothing
but here's the thing whether or not game
insight really was in over their heads
and bit off more than they can chew
we have to remind ourselves who the
actual victims are here the players and
for them it doesn't really matter what
excuse this developer has
we're coming out of a global pandemic
here times have been and continued to be
tough for a lot of people one of my
teammates was depending on this money he
lives in Spain right now he cannot find
a job
well during the time of Kobe 19 and he
was counting on this money another team
when I marked like old friends he was
also a lot of people were dependent on
this money and they were getting
desperate hey we really need this money
or we keep telling them but they seem
not to care the fact that here today 9
months after the event concluded that
the players are still being given these
vague promises of being paid someday
somehow at some point is simply
unacceptable and at this point no excuse
is satisfactory would you guys like to
see the most badass Star Trek comic of
all time Star Trek The Next Generation
mirror broken shiz hell about us check
this [ __ ] out
this is like Star Trek for alpha males
everybody has sleeveless uniforms
everyone's jacked to [ __ ] everyone has
eyepatch ah's and [ __ ] even date is
jacked and he's a robot
look at this come on come on there's a
scene of Captain Picard bench-pressing
come on this is sick this the ship was
just made for me they took the
enterprise and they just put a giant as
laser gun on the front that's badass bro
Captain Picard
jacked and sleeveless is who I aspired
to be